[Música]
la depresión es la causa principal de
discapacidad en el mundo en eeuu casi el
10% de los adultos sufren de depresión
sin embargo al tratarse de una
enfermedad mental es más difícil de
entender que el colesterol por ejemplo
una causa importante de confusión es la
diferencia entre padecerla y simplemente
sentirse deprimido casi todo el mundo se
siente desanimado de vez en cuando
recibir una mala calificación perder el
empleo tener una pelea incluso un día de
lluvia puede inspirar sentimientos de
tristeza a veces no hay ni siquiera una
razón aparece de la nada luego las
circunstancias cambian y los
sentimientos de tristeza desaparecen la
depresión clínica es diferente es un
problema médico y no desaparecerá solo
porque quieres tiene una duración de al
menos dos semanas y afecta la capacidad
de trabajar divertirse o la vida amorosa
puede presentar diversos síntomas apatía
pérdida de interés por lo que
generalmente te gusta cambios en el
apetito sentirse inútil o muy culpable
dormir demasiado poco dificultad para
concentrarse estar muy agitado o lento
tener falta de energía o pensamientos
suicidas recurrentes si tienes por lo
menos cinco de estos síntomas según las
directrices psiquiátricas encajas en el
diagnóstico de la depresión y los
síntomas no son simplemente de conducta
la depresión se manifiesta físicamente
en el cerebro en primer lugar hay
cambios observables a simple vista y con
rayos-x que incluyen lóbulos frontales e
hipocampo más pequeños
a escala microscópica la depresión se
asocia con ciertas cosas la transmisión
anormal la reducción de ciertos
neurotransmisores
especialmente serotonina norepinefrina y
dopamina ritmos circadianos alterados o
cambios característicos en las fases rem
o alfa de los ciclos de sueño y
disfunciones hormonales como aumento en
los niveles de cortisol y desregulación
de las hormonas tiroideas pero sin
embargo los neurocientíficos no tienen
una imagen completa de lo que causa la
depresión parece que tiene que ver con
la interacción compleja entre la
genética y el medio ambiente pero no es
una herramienta de diagnóstico capaz de
predecir con precisión dónde y cuándo se
va a producir como los síntomas de la
depresión son intangibles es difícil
saber quién la padece aunque parezca
saludable según el instituto nacional de
la salud mental en eeuu una persona
común con una enfermedad mental demora
más de 10 años en pedir ayuda pero
existen tratamientos muy eficaces
medicación y terapia se complementan
para estimular la química del cerebro en
casos extremos la terapia de
electroshock que es una convulsión
controlada inducida en el cerebro del
paciente también ayuda mucho otros
tratamientos prometedores como la
estimulación magnética transcraneal
también ayuda mucho
así que si conoces a alguien que sufre
de depresión alienta a esta persona
amablemente a que considere algunas de
esas opciones puedes ofrecerte para
ayudar en tareas concretas como buscar
terapeutas en la zona o hacer una lista
de preguntas para consultarle al médico
para alguien con depresión estos
primeros pasos pueden parecer
insuperables si esa persona se siente
culpable o avergonzada explicarle que la
depresión es un problema médico como el
asma o la diabetes no es una debilidad o
un rasgo de la personalidad no debe
creer que puedes superarla y recuperarse
así como no lo haría si tuviera un brazo
roto si tú mismo no ha sufrido de
depresión evita comparar la enfermedad
con momentos en que estaba desanimado
comparar su experiencia con los
sentimientos normales pero fugaz es de
tristeza normal los puede hacer sentir
culpables por su sufrimiento incluso
hablar abiertamente sobre la depresión
puede ayudar por ejemplo la
investigación muestra que hablar de
pensamientos suicidas en realidad reduce
riesgo de suicidio las conversaciones
francas sobre las enfermedades mentales
ayudan a acabar con el estigma y hacer
más fácil pedir ayuda y cuantos más
pacientes busquen ayuda más científicos
avanzarán en la investigación de la
depresión y los tratamientos serán más
eficaces
gracias por mirarte ted en español si le
gustó este vídeo haga clic en
suscribirse y no se pierda ningún vídeo
que valga la pena compartir
ah